all right Godwin is with us in
Washington DC is a god one a good one
Godwin Godwin how are you hey good my
question is my wife and I we started
your program in February we started with
thirty three thousand dollars worth of
debt
I sold my vehicle because it was about
half of that it was sixteen thousand
dollars I got a loan from my credit
union for six thousand I used that to
pay the difference because the car was
upside down and I used three thousand or
that to purchase a truck I'm trying to
start a business which is why I went and
got a truck now after buying the truck
it came with the snow plow and a salt
spreader and I'm coming to find out the
truck is worth probably about 9 grand so
the question is do I sell the truck or
do I hold on to it and use it to make
money in the wintertime especially most
the time out here in DC we do get pretty
big storms you bought up a nine thousand
dollar truck for three thousand I bought
it for three thousand yah what happy how
did they do that I have no idea the
dealership just tasered I don't know how
they messed up but yeah it came with us
with the snow plow a truck yeah I got
that in the spreader yeah
so I'm wow that's amazing that's awesome
what's your household income we make
about forty five grand a year and what's
the other car you have worth the other
cars we owe 85 on it's probably worth
that or a little bit less okay so the
total of your cars is less than half
your annual income and you have how much
debt left to pay off you have about 19
thousand left no I would keep the truck
the truck is yeah I'm going to use it to
make money you got a good deal on it
it's not out of line it's uh if it was
nineteen thousand I'd probably sell it
by the way so but here's here's the rule
of thumb I uses two things okay with
cars number one is you don't want to
have cars or things with motors in them
totaled up because everything with a
motor in it goes down in value okay and
I like things with motors
I'm a boy all right so I want I like
that but everything with a motor in it
goes down in value so you don't want to
have things with motors and I'm totaled
up that are over half your annual income
because then you end up with too much
going down in value while you're trying
to build wealth and it kills you and so
people with you know boats and cars and
motorcycles and four-wheelers all
sitting around and it all adds up to 50
grand and they make 50 grand well that's
why they're broke you see what I'm
saying yeah and so even if it's all paid
for you don't want to have too much
invested in things going down the second
rule of thumb I use is can you pay off
all of your debts not counting your
house inside of two years without
selling the vehicle and you like the
vehicle well you like the vehicle I like
the vehicle because it's going to make
you money not just cost you money with
the snowplow and the salt spreader and
so we like the vehicle now is it is it
you are you in a situation where you can
be debt-free everything but the house
within two years and the answer is yes
yes
so the under those two guidelines that's
how I decided to give you the advice to
keep the truck and that way next time
when you're looking at it you can decide
for yourself and you won't need me so
very cool man thanks for the call hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or a five
hundred thousand dollar ending
you